gratulations
on pop culture quest I loved watching it
because it's my favorite thing about you
as you are a fanboy yourself so it's
great to watch you I think that's why
you're so great with your fan well
because I am a fan you are a fan and
they know that they know I'm not posing
them and I'm not making fun of them in
any way and then there's a certain
shared passion that we have and it's
universal it doesn't matter if I don't
collect the specific item that you
collect
it's that same we have the same
motivation in terms of collecting bump
the pop culture quest my chance to keep
collecting through you what's the most
impressive piece of Star Wars
memorabilia that you come across
well George rejected the first Chewbacca
masks because he was snarling and they
had bared teeth because I don't want
that I want a passive now so he looks
like a friendly Wookiee so he gave me
the prototype and that's the key if you
get a prototype something that's not
mass-produced it's always more valuable
it's not meant you know to to before the
public that's that's sort of a rare
prototype and I stress to all potential
burglars
out there it's not at my house it's in
storage
[Music]